hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the pedestrian I Oh F huh
f
I'm effing I'm effing as hard as I can
with oh oh oh oh f Oh F I'm f
I'm all dumb all kinds of F huh oh oh oh
f Oh F okay guy whoa okay so what
happens if I move this out of the way
and almost there wait Oh almost right
there no okay how about I just do this
hope you ski it it it it it
whoa that's cool
why that's so cool
what the heck whoa look at awesome
what okay so alright hang on a second
everybody I I had no idea what this game
was about when I saw the game I saw a
very limited window into the game this
is beyond anything that I had known
before I had no idea that this was the
game I am just delighted cuz it's
something so new that I've never seen
before this is a puzzle platformer that
I've I've never known I've never known I
have no idea okay I'm gonna stop
freaking out about nomina try to get
this generally in order here so what I
need to do now I need to break this
connection and I just need to connect
this to here
what oh wait a minute no I can't do that
so what I need to do is break this
connection put this here
No aah I need to go here and that I need
to go here oh my brain hurts oh but
that's oh that's not neato burrito wait
okay so if you break that connection it
sends you back to the beginning so you
have to figure out a way to do it
without that so if you go through here
close this and break this you get sent
back to the beginning can let try this
way again because unless I missed an oh
okay so you just need to press down to
be able to go through that
oh that's puzzling oh that's pedalling
yes thank you for the tutorial but I
think I got this one there we go there
we go Oh neat oh that is okay the reason
I'm freaking out about this and I don't
mean to freak out too much about this
because this is a cool concept but I
want to be very very very sure about
what I'm doing before I have to do it
but it's just a concept that is in fact
new and interesting I have never seen
anything like this this is like a
mixture of portal and gosh numerous of
other things possibly but like just the
concept of mixing and matching the
levels while you're also in a different
world like outside of these pedestrian
signs which is kind of the concept this
is just really freaking cool and I
really freaking like it but either way I
need to be smart about this I need to go
here drop through there to here and then
go up through there and that's what I
need to do and the idea that you can do
it in whatever configuration that you
want is also just super darn interesting
and unique and that's the thing that I
love about this is that it's so unique
and I almost missed this completely
because I barely saw where I was going
where am i and also where am i that's so
interesting the fact that I'm in a
warehouse and I'm a guy on a sign
the depth of it is just really
intriguing to me to see how deep we
actually go here Oh Eddie to get the key
and also to do a lever and also to throw
a box and that's really cool the way
tutorials are done and the
happy-go-lucky music of it it all
combines to a really interesting
experience but that's the last I don't
want to freak out about this because now
I'm probably gonna have to use my brain
about this but obviously I'm gonna tell
you even before I get through this game
you can play this for yourself there's a
link down the description below play it
it's freaking awesome I like it a lot
and you guys can too so you got to kind
of think of it like completely outside
the box because I don't need to go in
there first I can't go in there first I
have to go through here first right
there get that key go through this door
go over here through this door unlock
that and then climb my way out up here
it's like it's a really interesting way
of looking at it through an overview
while also planning inside for what they
are and I can't wait to see what other
concepts are gonna come through this
where am I going this delightful oh
where am I now yes see I need to get a
key before I'm able them through here so
I got to find a way to get up there but
that ladder is too high up for me to do
that so I got to go down it so I got to
go down through the ladder first no this
one first so I gotta go down then
through there but how do I do that
cuz I gotta get the key but I'm not
gonna be able to do that hmm that's a
puzzle so I can only go through the door
on the left I can't quite reach the door
above me so I'm gonna have to go down
through the ladder first whoo I think I
know I got to find the limit with which
this will reach yeah like that oh my god
that's awesome that's awesome
down we go and through there and up
above oh my god my brain hurts and then
I can just drop down through here and go
through there and in oh it's so
delightful it's so delightful where am I
going now Oh is there like a dark secret
to this as to why there's a freakin dude
oh my god blades what is that what is
that I have no idea
oh so cool what's in the background
they're playing on the screen I mean
kind of water reminds me of is the
environment of Stanley parable without
the narrator dragon day you're dragging
you down to hell no let's store you two
people meeting are they gonna go on a
date and fall in love forever power of
imagination I suppose and this
pedestrian guy being enclosed in a box
forever and unable to escape oh yes oh
so much yes okay wait before I do
anything let me get an overview whoa
whoa Nelly
okay so the only thing that I can do is
connect this ladder to this I wonder if
anybody walking by this warehouse just
suddenly freaked out at the fact that
the pedestrian signs are thinking for
themselves I don't know
but if they are oh well there we go all
right got it
huh all right jumped Jim here buddy a
hobbit hibbett I grab that get through
there go down there up and it up yeah
you actually have to plan through the
whole thing before you're actually done
or else you're gonna get stuck and dead
heard ended heard it nerve the durdle
okay
skedaddle doodle ah I wonder how they
even came up with this concept like the
concept of Edessa ensign being able to
move through its own world and also
being able to go through all these
different worlds and somehow when I'm
moving through these places it's not
automatically taking me there I have to
manually walk through so literally my
guy is going through tunnels in like a
fourth dimensional [ __ ] area of this
entire universe and traveling through
this thing but to what end I want to
know I want to know why and I want to
know for what reason but we're gonna
find out what is that oh the lever
controls that that goes there whatever
the hell's over there on the right is
something or other oh now we're getting
a lot of pieces here in my brain
starting to curve buckle right so
there's two ladder points one is there
when it's definitely on the exit so I'm
assuming this is gonna be the last one
because it needs to be
at the end of it and that's an elevator
that's gonna take me up and down so when
I come out of here I got this has got to
connect to this apparently maybe okay so
that's gonna connect to that let me make
that relatively easy even to be pleasing
to the eyes II oh boy yeah okay there we
go all right so start there go through
there and then back now that's gonna be
interesting maybe this can just be an
add-on room over here that you have to
go to like eventually and I'm gonna move
it all just cuz I like having the
ability to have this all where I need it
to be smooth that's that's the other
thing I was trying to think of the right
word you're doing your own level design
I mean the level is designed the way it
is and it's supposed to be that way but
it's also you're like an amateur level
designer here and you got to think about
the intricacies of the level oh no you
guys think about the intricacies of the
level itself while also getting you out
of the way oh I really hope it keeps up
with the puzzle elements because if
there's good stuff continuing all the
way through this then this could be the
potential to something really like
legitimately incredible here because
there is just doodles and skadoodle z'
of potential here okay so I need an up
to go to this down but that down needs
to go to the up so I gotta hit this room
before I hit that room like I start here
okay so this is gonna go for a key which
is gonna go there but I don't need to go
there yet I can go through there later
so this is next this is after so this is
next when we go up here so that connects
there that connects there okay so we're
gonna crisscross a bit we're gonna Chris
over here we're gonna cross over here
stretch this a bit farther just for
logical reasoning sake okay I think
that's gonna be it right all right okay
here we go ha Bisky
all right got a key her buddy Bert Bert
Oh so delightful
we whoo oh my god that's far HAP hope
yep okay and now my ride all right don't
squish me and there we go Oh jiggledy
jam
I'm tickled I gotta stop being tickled
yeah is there death over there oh just a
spring Lee [ __ ] awesome that's a cool
way of doing it because it's introducing
new concept oh oh no it's so good oh
it's so good oh it's such a good idea I
love it
oh I'm so gonna support this I'm gonna
support this right now I don't think I
have a Kickstarter oh man this is such a
good idea I really hope this Kickstarter
is still going Skookum - arts okay the
pedestrian a great idea great idea great
idea fantastic idea okay so they are
greenlit I'm assuming that Kickstarter
was successful because this was greenlit
a while ago and there hasn't been an
update yet but this is a great idea I
legitimately hope this goes somewhere
because this is such a unique and
interesting concept the the level design
of it the aspects of the intricacies of
the background of the level and also the
level that you're in like it all
combines into very pleasant experience
and I think there's so much potential
here so either way that is the
pedestrian let me know what you think of
this and you can play this demo for
yourself write down the description
please I want to hear your feedback on
this one because this game is cool so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
by